hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play limbo okay stop
we got this situation going on here
where there's a bug and I apparently
have to creep up on him also slowly
oh so slowly so very slowly
concentration must be adhered to calmly
quietly slowly Oh only calmly quietly
today not today bug today very slowly
call me
gladly slowly slowly calmly quietly so I
hit on girls at clubs calmly quietly the
trick is not to startle one
I gotta
no bad okay I got to get really close
same with women just got get really
close next thing you know you're banging
right into him yeah totally
totes man that's totes how I get the
women hang on I got this okay
oh they're good hmm yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah nah ah come on what what the hell
I'll take you what the hell
what what the hell man hey yeah hey dick
get it good good good
turn it in yeah yeah yeah gonna grab
legs yeah yeah yeah don't don't be
afraid run ah okay so it's like right
here that it gets startled no matter
what okay
yeah I got this uh-uh uh-uh
Oh damnit so I got a it's about how
successful I am with women - wait did I
forget how to like run or something no I
did huh do the creep
ah it's right here uh I got ya got ya I
got ya got ya
because I go jump off for what
aha how you like me now or your legal
duty hahaha that's that's not what I do
and then after I meet them that's not no
no I don't do that maybe there was a
secret up there
maybe if I jumped off him at the right
time it would have been able to get up
there but oh well that opportunity has
passed I no longer have the capability
of doing that all right what we got here
hmm
this seems obvious terribly obvious but
it obvious enough I even need to do that
I don't do me just had swirly mmm and it
was delicious
all right would have got up here
Oh junk get up there
user yes my axe your head in the wall oh
it's a good idea got away oh oh
oh I see
ah I see I see it I see this illusion
oh no no momentum damn your momentum
I got this I got it a rude girl it's
doing like an old car horn because as a
car tire ah
come with me if you want to be
if you are a living object over trying
it very quickly
alright now what's the deal with that
Oh Tommy Tommy Tommy now we have a tire
but why do we have a tire forward
purpose what happens tire in existence
yeah
okay I think I know what
but no get over there pushy BuChE BuChE
it up the hill then I let it go and I
run and I don't know why okay okay if if
I had this year I could come
why don't I need to do that can i oh oh
good good
damn it damn it gonna happen again
nope or no all right whatever I stupid
anyway I push it up the hill again not
that I care
I piss you the bishop hill did I let it
down I run away from you Oh bill you got
what's really really you son of a [ __ ]
you son of a [ __ ]
- I never bit okay shine up a [ __ ] oh
he's gonna kill me in it gonna kill me
ah ha ha I am the winner
I'm the winner oh look how awesome I am
with my box oh that box ever
oh yeah you yeah do my box with me let
me go box
go get on this boom a little visit we're
gonna bet it oh yeah you got weight hey
box box box okay you better be okay box
you better be okay without me but I
swear if you bark if you die box yeah Oh
box is going down and box died
okie-dokie me w ah there is box hanky
box I knew I needed box for some reason
coming Gaja thank you for your box your
[ __ ]
I need two boxes
I know what I need I need that other box
oh I'm in a box
come yeah let me down I'll fine I'll
fool you and then I'll finish you babies
you any name I I'll go down with you
yeah box leaved now I will push you in
this regard don't I pitched a budget I
jump on you yeah oh so great on the best
oh I'm so smart
ah get back here ah dammit
yeah come here come here come here
hey hey let's get what get out what do l
oh I know you swing one way did I call
it back
swing one way yeah totes man took to it
ah leave me don't leave me gooo
okay I'm doing something wrong hmm maybe
if I jump on it and start winning
oscillation then then I will get it
and then I jump and then I hit the
button in the back
ah damn it OOP yeah Oh who's the
smartest ever oh yeah
much of this child is dead what child is
dead
wait what's going on what's going on huh
I Bears you I boost
well
Oh
this doesn't seem good this seems very
fun good less than good war boy
something's happening I feel that
thing's gonna swing open yep there it is
don't didn't get me pop a demon fine
fine
looks good to me why this is happening
hurry go oh no it's done I can't move it
Oh what get off of there I'm finished
oh no I don't I don't pray I Bruce you
I get it I magnetized it right when it's
in the right place wrecker
oh no it's not in the right place
hey Evie she baby Oh reckon so good
totes it man
now watch this Oh Lee everything is for
jump one ah second fun yeah yeah I can
make that yeah oh yeah yeah whoop-whoop
what what we gotta whoop was that that
was not a whoop that was less than open
up and whoop oh yeah Oh can't believe
how awesome I am oh yeah and that's
probably all the time I got for this hip
suit thank you everybody for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
part
bye-bye